Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Did you sleep well?
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 69th episode!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
We're almost at 70!
Almost 70!
BAU BAU!
Wow, for ruffians who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Nice BAU BAU!
Are you BAU?
BAU the best!
Almost at 70.
Right?
Right!
We haven't slept in.
We haven't, ruffians!
We haven't slept in!
Right?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Happy morning.
Seems sleepy.
I have a big problem.
What?
Ruffians.
Surely it's too cold and you know Pero's not quite around, right?
He's somewhere warmer.
You know, like in the middle of the earth or something.
The middle of the earth!
Somewhere warm, you know.
There has been another Pero sighting.
Why?
I think the ruffians just have too sharp eyes.
Sharp eyes, huh?
Wow!
Pero was spotted!
De-den!
Oh!
You saw Pero on your campus!
But you gave him a scarf and a hat!
You know, that's really kind of you.
Good idea to tea him like that.
Yeah, you know it.
Have you stared into the little black eyes of his before?
Try it.
Ruffian stare.
Do it.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, he does look very warm, he does.
A bit fluffy and fuzzy even!
Like, like a cute grandma!
I'm pretty sure!
Yeah, he does look like a cute grandma.
Yeah, but don't, don't be fooled by fans, okay?
He's not a grandma.
He's Pero.
Yeah.
He won't be knitting.
He won't be drinking tea.
He's up to nasty stuff, okay?
Guys, he's Pero, okay?
He's not your grandma!
You're being fooled, okay?
No.
You can change him.
No, Pero's Pero.
Pero is nasty.
Yeah, don't fool yourself, okay?
Ruffians, please make sure, be careful if you see him around, okay?
If someone comes up to you and says that they're your grandma, don't believe them.
Don't believe them, okay?
BAU BAU!
I'm a bit concerned about the ruffians.
You're being too kind, ruffians!
You can't be deceived that easily, okay?
Be careful.
You have to be careful.
Avoid eye contact.
Exactly.
Well!
We have some...
Happy New Year!
Ruffians!
Exciting things are going on!
It was just announced that FUWAMOCO will be participating in the hololive X capsule collab for the lantern festival in Tainan!
BAU BAU!
We're so excited!
Look at us, the ruffians!
Together with our senpai!
The club, for a bit more information.
The club will be going on from February 24th.
So about a month from now.
February 24th to March 10th.
There will be a bunch of fun things to check out.
Ruffians will keep on getting more and more surprises.
Oh!
This!
That too!
Oh my gosh.
It's our first time being invited to something like this.
We're really, really happy!
We can't wait for the event to start, so hopefully you decide to go check out and enjoy the lantern festival with us in Tainan!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, it must be our first time.
Got it!
Got it.
Well, you might already know.
But, you know, usually, Ruffians, we have a weekly collab with Advent, right?
We do!
But this week, instead of our regular collab, we're doing something really special!
Yeah, we're gonna be having our first ever Advent Karaoke Relay!
It will start at 6PM PT, just like usual.
And we'll all be singing for 30 minutes each.
FUWAMOCO, Shiori, Biboo, Nerissa, then FUWAMOCO!
Yeah.
Ah, but.
But.
Yeah.
This time, you know, we're actually going to be doing an unarchived karaoke at the end to count it off.
Yeah!
This is unarchived.
That means you definitely can't miss it, right?
Right!
Yeah.
Oh boy, I wonder what the other girls will be singing.
Right!
We're not sure if it's going to be archived or unarchived, so you'll definitely need to be there.
You have to be there!
We're really looking forward to all the fun singing that we're going to have and listening to Advent's beautiful singing voices too.
Everybody's so unique.
Let's make sure to prepare our palettes, okay?
Lots of fun.
BAU BAU!
Who is Bijou?
I don't know.
The sparkling gem of Advent.
Biboo.
If Bijou is the sparkling gem of Advent, then...
Who's Biboo?
Biboo Koteki.
Biboo Koteki?
Got it.
Koteki.
Okay.
That's who it is.
Biboo Koteki.
Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Ino.
We actually had something very special happen.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
The other day, one of FUWAMOCO Morning's idols, Naruse Eimi, Eitaso!
She was a member of Dempagumi Inc., an idol group that we really, really liked!
Definitely one of our favorites.
She tweeted,
BAU BAU!
I feel really really happy!
But a bit embarrassed too!
She was my favorite member back when she was a part of the group and actually I still think about her a lot.
BAU!
You know, she always wanted to be a bright source of light for everyone.
Kind of like the sun, you know?
And she absolutely did that.
You know, Dempagumi...
They always said that their rival was in another idol group, but actually pretty cute!
And actually, Eitaso even became the seiyu for PreCure Star!
Elite Star Twinkle PreCure.
Yeah!
BAU BAU.
Actually, you know, Icomochi-mama is also a really big fan of Denpagumi, too.
Right!
We can't wait to chat with Icomochi-mama about Denpagumi stuff, too.
Yeah, you know, we could talk for a very, very, very long time.
But hopefully we can sing more Denpagumi songs at our rock n' rawr parties, too.
Right.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
Yesterday there was a lot going on, but actually, Ichijo Ririka of ReGLOSS, she had a stream where she learned some English phrases, some words from us hololive English members!
Did you check it out?
It was really silly and cute to see her do her best,
Rai tried to learn as much as she can.
I don't know if we're a really good example, but... Well... We're something.
Yeah, we shared the line.
You know, have a howl of a day!
But... That aside, for some reason, Ririka... She says she wants to become a sandwich with us.
Huh?
A sandwich?
That doesn't have to do anything with our... Our line.
We're not.
Not have a sandwich!
No!
Not have a sandwich today!
We're not food!
We're demon dogs!
Yeah!
Ruffy and fuzzy!
Not food!
Not a sandwich!
I don't think you want your food very fluffy or fuzzy, huh?
No.
No fluffy fuzzy sandwiches.
That's what I thought, but it seems, ruffians, that there was a lot of other viewers that felt the same in the chat, too.
Huh.
Why?
We're not food, you know that, right?
I'm not a hot dog!
No!
No.
Hot dog?
That's more like Korone-senpai.
Wait, which hololive- We're saying we're not food, but we're saying that Korone-senpai could be food.
Could be food.
Wait.
Which hololive member is best suited for consumption then?
I thought you said Mikocchi-senpai, right?
Ah, but that's Mikocchi-senpai the cookie.
Watame-senpai!
Probably.
There's no excitement in that.
Why?!
Subaru-senpai!
I like Subaru-senpai as an ice cream cone.
Why?
Luna-senpai!
Luna-senpai could be hard to join.
Yeah, Kiara-senpai, there's no excitement in that either.
Oh, Ame-senpai, because she's a little Ame.
Ame.
Okayu-senpai, of course!
I would like a warm bowl of Okayu-senpai!
Thank you!
Okay.
Decided.
That took too long, huh?
Ruffians, we might not keep your tummy full, but maybe not like a nice bowl of okaeshi soba.
But we can keep you warm!
Let's all feel fuzzy.
Maybe we can also keep your heart full, too.
But not your tummy.
But we hope that Ririka continues to do her best getting English.
We'll do our best to improve our Japanese too.
BAU BAU!
Mogumogu kaiyo.
Ruffians.
Did you get a good sleep last night?
Rest those eyes, rest those paws.
Go zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom.
Bijou.
Meow!
You too, thankfully!
Not really.
Moco-chan!
You have something to say, maybe?
Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
I'm sorry!
Last night!
During my climb on Watchalong.
I got pretty sleepy there, huh?
Pretty early on.
I started...
You know, I was doing my best, but I started to do it off here and there, huh?
Yeah.
I definitely did not sleep talk about castles, you know what I mean?
No!
Definitely no sleep talking!
Definitely not, yeah.
Dangerous.
But it wasn't because I wasn't interested or it was slow or anything.
No.
I like this sort of stuff, you know, but... I was just so sleepy.
Yeah, it was a busy day, you know.
Yeah.
And then... It was sad and then... I didn't cry or anything!
My eyes definitely are not puffy!
No!
One moment Moco-chan sleeping next to you, and next moment there's tears streaming down her face?
No.
Well, I'm hoping that tonight, maybe, we'll be a bit more energetic.
Maybe.
Okay!
Because you know we have our second half of the watch along tonight.
Yeah.
More energy!
Why?
You didn't sleep?
Ah, you didn't!
You didn't!
Ah, I... But you did sleep.
I wonder what that means.
Why?
Why sleepy?
Bring a pillow!
Why?
Actually, Moco-chan.
I also need to confess to you.
What now?
Why?
I was really, really sleepy too!
Really, really!
Yeah, but I know you know that I need to be strong since I'm the oldest sister, you know?
Yeah, so that's why I let you doze off.
Because I wanted to too.
But I didn't!
I did!
Okay!
Ruffians!
Are you proud?
Are you proud of me?
I'm not proud of you.
Be proud of me too!
I didn't steal Moco-chan's energy.
I was doing my best.
I stole my energy.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, ruffians!
Well, you know, Kano is a really great, classic, legendary anime, so we'd really like it if you continue watching it along with us!
We just finished off Mocoto's storyline, so I think, you know, if you jump in with us right now, it'll be fine too!
Maybe, you know, we'll also have a summary for those who weren't there, or for those who dozed off like me a bit.
Doing the first part of it!
Yeah.
So it's okay!
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, you'll do better today, right?
I'll do my best.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Does this count as another confession?
Something funny is happening, ruffians.
You know, the other day, we kinda stumbled upon something strange.
Ruffians, have you noticed something?
Have you noticed a greeting?
There's something very unnecessary.
Something that shouldn't be included in it.
Yeah.
We're a bit shocked.
You know, even a little disturbed.
You know, I thought, wow, that's not the kind of thing I want to be sharing, but, well, it's been every stream we've done.
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Do you see?
See?
I'm serious!
There's a hidden air horn in our meeting this entire time!
It's the air horn!
I can't believe it, Ruffians!
We're really, really sorry!
We didn't mean to be blasting the air horn at you every time!
But now it's too late!
We can't go back!
FUWAMOCO Air Horn.
Sorry, ruffians.
Now you're gonna hear it every time!
You get used to it!
Well, hopefully, you'll learn to love our horns.
Right?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
That's all we can hope for now, right?
Cuz we can't change things.
We can't change it!
You just have to love it now, huh?
Yeah.
Well, ruffians, are you awake?
Are you feeling good now?
Now that you heard the air horn!
I guess.
Maybe.
You wanna hear from me?
Air horn's not good enough?
What do you think, ruffians?
Air horn good enough?
Ha!
Ah, it's good now.
You don't want?
Okay.
Doggie of the Day time.
BAU!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... That.
No!
Okay.
I guess it's that time then.
Ruffians!
It's that day of the week.
It's today!
Today you're gonna listen up close because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Hey!
Are your eyes feeling a bit heavy?
Has the cold been keeping you from getting going a bit?
Have you been telling yourself, just five more minutes?
A little more often than usual recently.
No way!
Okay.
Don't blame yourself for something that's normal, ruffians, okay?
It's dark.
It's chilly.
It makes sense for you to want to take some extra time to rest a bit.
And you know, you should never blame yourself for needing some rest.
You need to think that.
Rest is a very important part of being ready for what brings you.
Huh.
Okay.
It's not good to be constantly staying up.
Sleep is important, you know, so that you can face the difficulties both physically and emotionally.
So if sometimes you feel like you need a bit of a rest, you're feeling a bit bad or like you can't deal with something, maybe the best thing is to take a nap and just refresh a bit.
I know balance is important, and sleep is a big part of it.
So, be kind to yourself, okay?
By giving yourself what you need, a balance of hard work, rest, and relaxation, okay?
If you feel overwhelmed, just remember, okay?
I want you to be nice to yourself.
Got it?
Be nice!
Or, I'll bite you, okay?
You wouldn't want that.
So!
Let's all do our best for the rest of the week, okay?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
You're gonna do your best today, FUWAMOCO!
Ganbatte!
BAU BAU!
Next, we'll check out who's the Doggie of the Day today.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Dan!
It's Cooper!
Cooper.
Tiny.
Yeah.
But you know, even though Cooper is a little tiny, Cooper brings a big smile to your face too.
And you know what?
That's what he loves to do.
A dog with this like us.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
We're the same!
BAU BAU!
How does Cooper BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Don't let Cooper's tiny toes fool you, okay?
He's just a walkin', barkin', smilin' machine!
He's a good boy and he's ruffians his entire world too.
Yeah, he just wants to make you happy.
So, that's what he's going to do!
He's gonna do it!
Especially with that little pink tongue there.
And that little chocolatey nose.
BAU BAU!
And next for our today I went on a walk, we have De-den!
Slug!
All the snow.
BAU BAU!
And today for our question of the day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
There are some silly facts about different holomens about stuff they can't do, like how monsters they can't skip or sweets they can't whistle.
I was curious, are there any little things you two can't do?
This is a good one.
There are lots of things we can't do, right?
Try not to poke yourself in the eye.
Yeah, but I can't eat natto.
I am.
Slowly but surely, I can't eat cake.
Right, right.
If you look at it, right?
But we can't touch our toes.
We can't do whistle morsels.
Moco-chan, you can't buzz your lips.
Like warming up?
Yeah.
I can't do that.
Poruru-oneechan was laughing at you.
We can't open our eyes underwater.
But I can doggy paddle.
That's all I can do.
I can doggy paddle!
I don't know, maybe that's it.
It's kinda hard to think of, you know?
You don't think about those things.
Why?
To forget them.
Yeah.
We like to be able to think of the positive things, but you know, we can't skip!
Yeah!
We can definitely whistle!
Yeah.
You know, but even though there might be some things you can't do, it's just a temporary count, right?
Yeah!
If you just practice and work at it, then I think you definitely can, right?
Just like a natto, right?
Yeah.
So ruffians, don't forget about that either, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you for such a good question!
Thank you ruffians always for all your submissions!
Your Doggie of the Day!
BAU BAU!
Your questions, your Pero Sightings.
I really hope that Pero doesn't cross paths with you, but it sure seems like that's been common recently.
And also, the brand new FUWAMOCO Scoop!
Thank you so much, ruffians!
Don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMorning!
And also for your FUWAMOCO Scoop, hashtag FWMCScoop.
BAU BAU!
As for our next stream, we have tonight.
We're going to be watching the last half of the TV anime Kanon.
Yesterday, as you kind of know, we watched episode 1 to 12.
There was a moment where we laughed.
BAU BAU!
No pillows.
And for our schedule!
Let's take a look at the schedule.
On Thursday we're going to be playing Power Up.
It's a brand new game right now.
Early access, we're going to be playing it.
But not just FUWAMOCO, we're going to be playing it together with both Biboo and Shiori!
We're going to check it out all for the first time together.
It looks very fun.
Very silly.
Very silly song.
We hope that you'll check it out together with us.
I kind of have a good feeling about it, right?
It's very silly.
We're silly.
Together everything's fun with Biboo and Shiori, so...
Well, we'll see how it is.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians.
Thank you for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
I can't believe next episode will be episode 7.
Thank you always.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special Ruffians today.
Ishimundo!
BAU BAU!
Viva.
Fukie.
BAU BAU!
Kona.
Atlas Live.
BAU BAU!
Corindo.
Boredom.
BAU BAU!
Justic.
Hole Hunt.
BAU BAU!
The name I get.
Oh, Lunaria Phoenix!
BAU BAU!
Orange Moon!
Park Type!
BAU BAU!
Mega Tricycle!
After every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!